i uh wanted to cover yesterday's white
house press briefing live unfortunately
because of the schedule with the live
viewer town hall yesterday and different
things i just wasn't able to do it and i
regret it because there were just some
amazing moments at yesterday's white
house press briefing that i want to go
through many of these are instructive
and they tell us a lot about
number one the motivations of some of
the reporters in the white house press
briefing room um number two they really
open us up to very important
conversations about
law enforcement in today's case about
paternity leave in today's case and
about many different things so let's
start with the first one
the um
at this point familiar face in the white
house press briefing room fox news
reporter peter ducey
he was speechless speechless as he
attempted another another one of these
gotchas of white house press secretary
jenn saki
the topic here
was about um losing police officers to
vaccine mandates when of course the
reality is the number one cause of death
for law enforcement over the last year
has been coveted not getting shot in the
line of duty it's been covered we're
gonna play the lead up to this and you
will see eventually ducey is just he's
he's quite literally speechless he
doesn't know what to say and this is
just the continued attempted showboating
that he does
he maybe thinks this stuff makes him
look good it really is i mean he comes
off looking like a smurf here let's take
a look
here we go point of a vaccine mandate is
to make people safer but a vaccine
mandate also means tons of police and
military may walk off the job then at
the end of the day does a vaccine
mandate make people safe now it's really
important every time they talk about all
of these pilots might quit
all of these cops might quit remember
we had in for example we had the
massachusetts state police story oh uh
200 troopers or whatever mites
threatened
okay
one of them actually quit
and so with all of these things it
always has to be how many people are
actually quitting and getting fired
we're seeing that it's it's never more
than one percent in any organization we
found where are tons of police and
military walking off the job right
says that hundreds of thousands of u.s
service members remain unvaccinated
remain unvaccinated is different than
they are actually going to be off the
job
uh
which is leading to questions about
possible military readiness uh the la
county sheriff says that five to ten
percent of their
workforce could walk off the job and so
considering
the
i mean
is there any concern about that well i
would say what we point to or what i
would point you to is evidence with a
range of companies organizations frankly
the department of defense can also give
you the up-to-date statistics on members
of the military i believe it's over 90
percent but i would point you them for
statistics but there are other problems
in the world
then cloven 19. international terror
gang violence murder arson drug deal
what was the highest what was the what
was the number one cause of death among
police officers last year do you know
uh-oh
covert 19.
so that's something that we're working
to address and police departments are
working to address if you look at
seattle as an example which i know has
been in some of the reporting 92 percent
of the police force is vaccinated he's
very quiet now isn't he as are 93 of
firefighters 99 percent of seattle's 11
thousand employees have submitted
vaccine verification or an exemption
request safety though all these other
problems terror murder robberies
kidnappings is there any concern that if
police forces shrink or if the size of
the ready military force shrinks
that
the united states for localities may not
be equipped by the way the military
question is funny because
the military is not supposed to be used
for domestic enforcement of laws and
there are of course as we know
situations where governors can call out
state national guards but like trump's
idea of sending the military down to the
u.s
uh mexico border to enforce
the border law that's actually against
the law you're you're not actually
supposed it's so funny that he talks
about we what about arson and the
military what does the military have to
do with arson or robbery nothing
properly to deal with peter more than
700 000 people have died of covid uh
again all right so you guys get the
point now of course any any one of you
should be saying david is it true is it
even true
that covet is the leading cause of death
for law enforcement this has been fact
checked many many times here is just one
example the officer down memorial page
details the cause of deaths causes of
death in the line of duty among law
enforcement officers in 2020 245
officers died due to covid contracting
covet in the line of duty that was the
majority of the 374 deaths in the line
of duty covid was by far the most common
recorded cause of death gunfire second
beginning in early 2020 due to
requirements of their jobs thousands of
law enforcement officers and first
responders contracted covid hundreds of
law enforcement officers died from
medical complications as a result of
contracting the virus while remaining on
duty and interacting with the community
a message at the top of the site reads
covet is the number one killer of law
enforcement officers in 2020 and 2021.
in 2021 237 coveted deaths were recorded
that also makes it a majority 369 total
deaths in the line of duty 237 for law
enforcement officers so it is indeed
true it is indeed true and you can just
see you know kind of the confusion on
peter ducey's face um there's always
some degree of confusion with all of
these things
and in this case
what we have to remember is covid
leading cause of death for law
enforcement
number two
threats to quit
or
people who are as of yet unvaccinated is
very different than
x percent of the workforce is now gone
united airlines was a big one where they
announced the vaccine requirement for
employees and then it was oh my goodness
look at all these people that are still
unvaccinated and as the deadline
approached and approached and approached
i think it was like one-third of one
percent of united employees actually
remained unvaccinated at the time of the
deadline one-third of one percent maybe
half of one percent or something like
that uh so always keep that in mind but
just
speechless speechless let's be honest
most health food snacks are not very
exciting they don't taste great they
don't fill you up one of our sponsors is
monk pack who makes amazing keto granola
bars that are sweet soft chewy and
filling with a slight crunch each has
only one gram of sugar
two to three net carbs and just 140
calories perfect for anybody doing low
carb or keto or if you just want a tasty
sweet snack without the sugar
everybody should be mindful of sugar
intake but you don't have to do so at
the expense of flavor because monk pack
keto granola bars come in delicious
flavors like coconut cocoa chip peanut
butter blueberry almond vanilla there
are other flavors too i can tell you
first hand they're all great i always
keep these in my pantry it's a perfect
snack during a busy day go to
monkpack.com link underneath this video
and you'll save 20 when you use the
promo code pacman at checkout